مقطع فيديو متداول لعازفه كمان انقطعت
اوتار قوسه خلال حفل موسيقي في بريطانيا
لكنه استمر بالعزف كان شيئا لم يكن مع
العلم ان قيمه القوس لوحده تبلغ حوالي 30
الف دولار لنشاهد ماذا حصل اثناء الحادثه
الغريبه وكيف تصرف العازف بسرعه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
انتشر مقطع فيديو مخيف يظهروا دوامته غبار
تبتلع طفلا خلال مباراه بيسبول في ولايه
فلوريدا الامريكيه واسرع الحكم لانقاذ
الطفل البالغ من العمر سبع سنوات من
الدوامه التي تشكلت بسرعه فائقه وتمكن من
اخراجه منها
مقطع فيديو اشتاح مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
يظهر تحركا غريبا للقمر بحجبه الشمس تماما
لثوان ليتم اكتشاف ان الفيديو مفبرك واكدت
هيئه مكافحه الاشاعات السعوديه ان الفيديو
معدل رقميا بالفعل وهو للفنان الاوكراني
اليكسي باتريف الذي نشر الفيديو على حسابه
في تيك توك عام 2021
[موسيقى]
قامت امراه تبلغ من العمر 77 عاما باتخاذ
قرار غريب حيث تزوجت من نفسها بعدما ضلت
طوال حياتها وحيده وبدات المسنه في غايه
سعادتها كما قررت شراء فستان زفاف وباقه
من الورود وجاءت بقص من الكنيسه ليتم
زواجها على نفسها بشكل رسمي في دار رعايه
للمسنين وقالت الحب هو اهم شيء في هذا
العالم واذا كنت تحب الله وتحب نفسك
فسيكون عالمك ممتلئا لحقول من الورود
هذا كانوا هذا كان كل شيء لليوم لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات